[Music]
totally groovy
hmm
did you like it
sorry
[Music]
hi i'm alyssa and i'm motoki and this is
expert amateur fraud a show where we try
to figure out who the expert is and
who's faking it and today we are
interviewing three
bartenders okay coolest people on the
planet
so i guess we might get a little tipsy
you're gonna have to be drinking for me
i actually
don't drink i'm
very cool and sober
and that's okay no what about you i mean
i drink yeah like you know every other
weekend i worked at a restaurant and i
became really good friends with the
bartender and he was like everybody's
best friends i was about to say that
yeah i'm a therapist yes i think that's
a good sign for a bartender
could you be my therapist
[Music]
hello bartender hello are you guys tired
because you had a late night
just woke up i think for round one will
you guys do some shots i think every
party you got to start with some shots
yeah right
all right sean
shot shots shot shot shots
oh wow what is that passion fruit
so this is a um a mixed shot so it's not
so spirit forward you're not gonna just
taste like alcohol
smells really good over here whoa you
got a cucumber i'm seeing this that the
way he's coming oh you're already done
oh wow oh my gosh okay it looks very
cute and seasonal yes timely for now yes
seasonal many orders of these this is
fun is this like a ring yeah
would you like to explain your shot to
us so this is a tiki
tequila shot passion fruit syrup some
coconut syrup rice pasado and then some
lime juice and then a little bit of
tahini on the rim
smells really good i think you're gonna
like that okay well cheers thank you for
making sure
[Music]
it's good it's got a nice little
sourness to it i'll take it a little
more a little please
[Music]
this is nothing fancy this is a play on
a whiskey sour ish a little bourbon a
little basil but the job of a shot is to
get you drunk okay we'll do that i feel
like you kind of went with like a
classic shot is just you know well when
you're when you're doing like high
volume in a bar you don't want to try to
dress it up you just gotta go
oh it's surprisingly sweet yeah it's
good i did i thought it would taste way
more like just straight alcohol okay
would recommend
what is this creation so this is the
apple pie shot so it's just one ounce of
um apple cider one ounce fireball topped
with a little whipped cream and a
cinnamon stick just to whatever make it
cute this is gorgeous and as a basic
fall girl
if starbucks sold out yes this would be
it i did used to work for them
yes like everyone i had a taste aversion
now to fireball because of a traumatic
experience in college
for the sake of video
[Music]
hmm
yeah did you like it
sorry
college is hitting again oh okay
fireball i understand i understand this
fireball like a college uh when you
drink too much
it can do some damage to you make sure
you're old enough to drink by the way
yeah make sure you don't have a drink
and don't drive
make us your favorite cocktail yeah
maybe your favorite one to make
maybe a popular one more muddling fresh
cucumber in here
just to get the essence of that cucumber
into the vodka oh cool
yeah shake that
up
[Music]
what is this called just your standard
kind of your standard bar kit yeah oh
wow you're already done yep okay you
kind of do it quick we're watching your
form
spank
all right so how much do you personally
care about presentation like that's
probably my favorite part oh okay yeah
it's kind of like self-care whoa love
that what's this yeah just so when you
take the first tip you get that hint of
lemon not lime set your palate for the
drink okay all right lulu's bar this
looks gorgeous this is my mood i would
say
where do you get this dried dragon fruit
i actually make those myself what you're
looking at right here
customers
it's good
i'm tasting multiple things like little
cucumber get the dragon fruit
orange liqueur yeah
thank you so much amazing job all right
kevin my dad's name is kevin good name
keep that in mind so this is something
that is pretty simple but it's pretty
kind of bar standard it's like a version
of like an east side which is kind of
like a vodka lime juice it's something
that's easy to make
basil in a cucumber called a boat you
guys
see this
where are you from kentucky
love it that's where my mom's from is
your dad from there too no
are you my dad
did you get started making drinks
yeah as a young black she started my
fraternity in college oh
you like it it actually has like um
similar qualities to the the shock yeah
yeah
he's got a style very similar it's one
of those things where you don't taste
the alcohol as much well here's the
secret is making the cocktails easy the
bark for the bartender to make and easy
for the customer to drink
so they drink more meat
kevin
michaela what is this gorgeous little
number so it's called a paper plane i
like to call it an italian sunset
because it has a lot of you know italian
colors in it so it's going to be bourbon
amaro which is like an herby liqueur
and then campari or you can use apparel
if you want a little sweeter so it's
gonna be pretty bitter before i drink it
though i want to see you hold that just
for fun hold it yeah he doesn't know how
to hold it okay cool yeah yeah okay if
you go like this you're gonna heat it up
faster so it's up to you oh
whoa that was kind of an interesting
tidbit well cheers i feel like great
gatsby
do you think that a bartender would know
that or just anybody would know that
about the heat eating
i that's a good that's a good
something to think about
[Music]
oh yeah that's strong
nice smell
smell taste
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is probably gonna be a fun one for
you guys
free for all yeah all right let the
games begin folks all right
they're off to the races
what's the most rewarding thing for you
as a bartender my love language is
pretty much hospitality business so just
contributing to everybody having a good
time that's what it's all about food fun
memories
exactly yeah well you make me feel good
all right
we got our speech
my mom and my dad well you're already
done
yes
maybe we distract lulu
whoa what'd you do i made a manhattan
this is what i like to end the night
with this is your favorite cup this is
my favorite cup yeah you've used it it's
cute twice
okay wow is that a pineapple slice yes
that is a grilled pineapple dehydrated
oh
lulu's classic garnishes that looks like
a flower
so this is just a jalapeno uh pineapple
margarita made with the reposado and
then of course tahini because it's
we love
that's really good i feel like this
would be a good like
barbecue drink wow cause the grill
you're getting the smokiness from the
grill pineapple the garnish it enhances
the ingredients with the essence so now
you're getting the smell of it when you
drink it so it's also bringing other
notes and stuff forward it does i feel
like i'm at a barbecue where's my
cousin
all right kev so this is a very very
classic simple cocktail okay known as a
mule i'm sure you've heard that mule
it's kind of what got me into bartending
it's just your simple kentucky meal oh
not a moscow moscow meals with vodka
kentucky moles with bourbon this is the
one drink i said because i don't drink
but i was like if i did drink i would
drink a mule yeah it's very simple to
make and it's not time consuming profit
people
really just go back to a mule get back
into kentucky kentucky roots this is
good once again pretty similar to your
other drinks now do you care about ice
at all i know some people are snobs
about ice i have to have a drink with
ice in it zeiss kind of brings out the
flavor of most alcohols i mean you're
about to say something oh ice is vital
you don't want thin hollow eyes because
once you shake you just automatically
water down your drink speaking of ice no
talk to us about this so this is a
manhattan two ounces of bourbon one
ounce of sweet vermouth so you don't get
the harsh taste of bourbon and then a
little bit of bitters and then a sweet
cherry on top to balance it out and it's
stirred in ice to make it cold
it's definitely alcohol
okay
do you feel like you like to talk to
your customers a lot oh yeah cause the
more you talk then they're gonna you
know drink their drink a little faster
again no profit so what made you want to
be a bartender um i started working at
starbucks
and i just liked you know the
creativeness high pace customer service
and people are more happy when you give
them booze instead of coffee at six in
the morning so sure right that was it
for the final round yeah that was the
final round you guys all did an
incredible job and you're all wonderful
it was fun it was fun it was also kind
of like intimidating yeah because
bartenders they're so cool it's hard to
tell because at the same time like
alcohol it's a little subjective right
even if i don't like a drink doesn't
mean that they prepared it wrong of
course so yeah you were obviously
drinking all of them i was not yeah
michaela's drinks to me seemed a little
more legit like she definitely like i
feel like went to some kind of school
for it now kevin
was very like hometown drinking
[Music]
i feel like it was very practical and
you said that most of his drinks tasted
the same they did what'd you think of
lulu i was like blown away by her
dehydrated
pineapple yeah
yeah i thought lulu's were great tasted
awesome presentation was spectacular but
at the same time like anybody on say
pinterest or tick tock could see like a
tutorial and recreate it so let's say
lulu is
i'd say i'm trying expert okay
um let me just take a sip of this
take a sip and then see
is that the drink of an amateur
[Music]
for the expert
we thought
it was
lulu you had
such a vast knowledge of not only like
the drinks you were making you were
making your own garnishes and grilling
and dehydrating them yeah presentation
wise like it was
really cool and if you're not the expert
then you had us duked yeah you had us
duped hardcore
when i was 21 i went to bartending
school and ever since literally that's
been my job i'm a slash bartender
mixologist beverage consultant mobile
bartending catering company with my own
brand being in the hospitality industry
especially now it can be really tough
yes you're going to learn drinks but
also do you have the capacity of having
thick skin and having patience with
customers explaining things to your
servers to your staff so that's that's
the main thing that i teach my students
first and foremost before they even get
behind the bar
so the amateur this is where it gets
tricky we are going to go with
michaela because you're wearing an apron
that convinced us
nothing else to be said i mean being
like a barista at first too it feels
like a seamless transition
[Laughter]
i did work for starbucks but i just work
at a computer i'm an analyst i do like
to make drinks in college i would make
my roommate mojitos all the time and i
do like to make myself a nice whiskey
drink before bed i have no experience
with bartending i mean
quarantine coved definitely made some
drinks at home not just like you know
vodka and root beer but like stuff with
some fruit and stuff wow kev
you're the amateur
wow you do have such like a confidence
about you and i initially when i first
like just saw everybody i was like
expert i feel like yeah you were kind of
going so fast and stuff we thought you
were like i don't know trying to just do
i gotta i bartended for years i don't
anymore i was in i was in hospitality
for 10 years until recently so i've done
positions from bartending to food and
beverage manager and my first bartending
job was a nightclub where i was able to
just crank him out no you killed it
as fast as humanly possible that's what
you kind of have to do
that was kind of funny was just looking
over at their drinks and i was like oh
that looks great and then looking over
it my kayla's drinks i was like oh that
looks great too it was like mine look
pretty shitty and it's gonna get them
thanks for the free outfit you guys
are all amazing good job
thanks for watching everyone hope you
enjoyed it did you guys guess right i
don't know we knew that lulu was the
expert and i'm gonna go home and be able
to sleep peacefully at night because of
that
and i will sleep well because of the
alcohol in my system
[Music]